ah
[Música]
el kremlin se enfrenta a una situación
muy complicada de gestionar ante el
rápido avance de los talibanes en
afganistán por una parte los talibanes
son considerados aquí en rusia como una
organización terrorista y la derrota de
la unión soviética de los años 80 está
todavía muy presente en el imaginario
colectivo de los rusos por otra parte
los talibanes se han hecho fuertes ya en
la frontera con tayikistán un país que
es aliado político económico y militar
del kremlin tanto es así que moscú ya ha
desplegado fuerzas militares en la
frontera entre afganistán y tayikistán
para asegurar la integridad territorial
de los tayikos además rusia se alegró
notablemente y públicamente de la salida
de eeuu de afganistán e inmediatamente
invitó aquí a representantes talibanes
para negociar las futuras relaciones
entre moscú y un afganistán en manos de
los talibanes de momento moscú ya ha
asegurado que no piensa retirar a su
personal diplomático de kabul
i
cuando el jefe de la diplomacia china
wang yi recibió el mes pasado una
delegación talibán se entendió que china
ya se estaba preparando para el nuevo
escenario y no sorprenderá que los
próximos días reconozca al nuevo
gobierno china sin embargo no pretende
ocupar el vacío dejado por eeuu sino que
tiene unos propósitos bastante más
humildes y compatibles con su principio
de no interferencia en asuntos externos
sin ha arrancado las promesas de que
serán protegidas sus inversiones y que
el país no se convertirá de nuevo en un
nido de terroristas es una cuestión que
le perturba especialmente por los
elementos radicales segures no es
probable que china quedara demasiado
convencida porque siguió pidiendo a sus
nacionales que abandonaran el país el
mayor peligro para china es que haya una
ola de inseguridad en toda la región no
sólo en afganistán sino también en
pakistán un país en el que tiene
innumerables
infraestructuras china quiere evitar que
se repitan sucesos como el reciente
atentado en el que murieron 9
trabajadores chinos en 9 las zonas con
mayor radicalismo religioso en pakistán
[Música]
los políticos alemanes como tantos otros
en la unión europea siguen muy de cerca
y con mucha preocupación la crisis está
actual en afganistán y no solamente por
lo que pueda significar para la
estabilidad del país para la estabilidad
de una región muy importante las
autoridades alemanas también están
particularmente preocupadas por la
seguridad de sus ciudadanos en
afganistán y por la seguridad de los
ciudadanos afganos que durante mucho
tiempo como traductores o en otras
labores similares apoyaron las labores
de las fuerzas militares alemanas en ese
país es importante mencionar que los
últimos soldados alemanes dejaron
afganistán a finales de junio también
hay mucha preocupación por el impacto
que pueda tener esta crisis aquí en
europa en particular en lo relacionado
con la migración hay quienes aseguran
que esta crisis en afganistán podría
desencadenar un nuevo flujo migratorio y
de ahí que haya llamados para hacer todo
lo posible para evitar una crisis
similar a la que vivió europa a partir
del año 2015
[Música]